Tenía 23 años
cuando por primera vez escuché sobre la justicia reproductiva.
Trabajaba en "Woman With A Vision",
donde aprendí que Sister Song definió la justicia reproductiva como:
Uno, el derecho de la mujer de decidir si quiere tener un bebé y cuándo tenerlo
y las condiciones en las que dará a luz.
Dos: el derecho de la mujer a decidir no tener un bebé
y elegir opciones para prevenir o interrumpir un embarazo.
Y tres: el derecho de la mujer a criar los hijos que ya tiene
en ambientes seguros y sanos
sin miedo a la violencia
por parte de individuos o el gobierno.
Siempre he querido ser madre.
En mi infancia, escuché todo sobre la dicha de ser madre.
Solía soñar con ver mi vientre gestar un milagro y traerlo a este mundo.
Bueno, yo sabía que era joven.
Pero supuse
que no sería malo comenzar a planificar algo tan grande, tan anticipadamente.
Pero ahora
tengo 26 años.
Y no sé si tengo lo que se necesita para ser madre en este país.
Bueno, durante años, Estados Unidos me ha enseñado más sobre crianza
que cualquier libro sobre la materia.
Me ha enseñado cómo algunas mujeres dan a luz a bebés
y otras dan a luz a sospechosos.
Me ha ensañado que este cuerpo dará a luz a familiares
que serán más propensos a ser encarcelados en prisión
que obtener un título de licenciado.
Existe algo acerca de ser negro en Estados Unidos
que ha hecho que el ser madre
parezca complicado.
Que parezca,
no sé qué hacer para criar a mis hijos correctamente
y mantenerlos con vida.
¿Le digo a mi hijo que no robe porque eso es malo,
o porque ellos lo usarán para justificar su muerte?
¿Le digo
que incluso si paga por sus Skittles y su té dulce
aun así existirán quienes lo mirarán
y verán como criminal antes que como niño
y llamarán a la policía y no esperarán que llegue?
¿Quiero realmente que llegue la policía?
Demasiados casos Sean Bell pasan por mi mente cuando considero llamar al 911.
No daré por sentado que no llegarán a matar a mi hijo.
Así, puede que nos hayamos deshecho de los ahorcamientos,
pero aún lo considero linchamiento cuando asesinan niños negros
y dejan sus cuerpos durante cuatro horas al sol.
Como un recordatorio histórico
de que existe algo acerca de ser negro en Estados Unidos
que hace que la maternidad se parezca
a estar de luto.
Que parezca que despertaré una mañana
y veré a mi hijo como la repetición de la noticia de la semana pasada.
Que parezca que despertaré y entenderé
que la muerte de mi hija ni siquiera será de interés periodístico.
No pueden decirme que Sandra Bland es la única mujer negra
cuya violencia merece más que nuestro silencio.
¿Qué hay de nuestras hijas de piel oscura en peligro
cuyas muertes aún nos quedan por recordar?
¿Qué hay de nuestros hijos
cuyas vidas no encajan bien en las vidas de los géneros determinados?
Al parecer, nada te protege realmente
si vienes desde un cuerpo que luce así.
Verán, existe algo acerca de ser negro en Estados Unidos
que hace que ser madre suene
como algo que no sé si aún anhelo.
He escrito muchos poemas sobre la muerte de niños negros para parecer ingenua
acerca del hecho de que un día podría haber un poema acerca de mis hijos.
Pero no quiero ser un monstruo que da a luz poemas.
No quiero una estrofa en lugar de un hijo
ni un verso en lugar de una niña pequeña
ni una nota en vez de un niño que no encaja en este mundo.
No.
No quiero hijos que vivan para siempre
en las páginas de poesía,
y que aun así parezcan no vivir más
que yo.
(Aplausos)
Me invitaron a la conferencia TEDWomen
para representar un poema.
Pero para mí, la poesía no se trata de arte y representación.
Es una forma de protesta.
Ayer,
durante el ensayo,
me dijeron que había habido
dos o tres charlas TED sobre Black Lives Matter.
Y que tal vez debería acortar mi charla TED
para que fuera solo sobre "justicia reproductiva".
Pero ese poema y esta charla
son fundamentalmente sobre mi incapacidad para separarlas.
Tenía 21 años...
(Aplausos)
Tenía 21 años cuando Trayvon Martin fue asesinado.
Trayvon Martin, un niño negro de 17 años,
un niño negro,
me recordó,
nos recordó
lo poco que esta nación valora las vidas de la gente negra.
El hashtag #BlackLivesMatter
se convirtió en la demanda más reconocida
para que la gente negra y nuestros hijos
vivan en ambientes seguros y comunidades saludables
sin miedo
a la violencia de individuos o del Estado o el gobierno.
Meses más tarde,
cuando George Zimmerman no se consideró responsable
de asesinar a Trayvon Martin,
escuché a Sybrina Fulton,
la madre de Trayvon Martin, hablar.
Su testimonio me impactó tan profundamente
que me encontré cuestionando constantemente
qué significaría ser madre en los Estados Unidos de América
con esta piel.
¿Qué significa realmente ser madre,
cuando para tantos que lucen como yo
es sinónimo de estar de luto?
Sin darme cuenta,
he empezado a conectar el contexto de la justicia reproductiva
y el movimiento por la gente negra.
Mientras aprendía sobre justicia reproductiva
en Women With A Vision,
y mientras seguía activa en el movimiento por la gente negra,
me encontré queriendo que otros vieran y sintieran estas similitudes.
Me encontré preguntándome:
¿En momentos como estos, quién se encarga
de conectar ideas, realidades y personas?
Quiero dedicar esta charla y este poema
a Constance Malcolm.
Ella es la madre de Ramarley Graham
que fue otro niño negro
que murió prematuramente.
Ella me recordó una vez en una cena,
mientras yo me esforzaba por escribir ese poema,
que ese es el trabajo del artista
el desenterrar historias que algunos intentan enterrar
con palas de complacencia y tiempo.
Recientemente,
Toni Morrison escribió que
en tiempos de temor,
los artistas nunca deben elegir guardar silencio.
No hay lugar para la autocompasión,
no hay lugar para el miedo.
Ayer, durante el ensayo,
cuando me dijeron que debería
"tal vez cortar la parte sobre Black Lives Matter de mi charla",
sentí temor.
Temía que otra vez se les negara a nuestras historias
los propios lugares donde merecen ser contadas.
Y luego recordé las palabras que acababa de decir.
En tiempos de temor,
los artistas nunca deben elegir guardar silencio.
No hay lugar para la autocompasión.
(Aplausos)
Y no hay lugar para el miedo.
Y tomé mi decisión.
Y siempre estoy decidiendo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)